you have two kids right uh yeah I have
actually I have three now because I just
got married in June to a woman that had
a child and I'm oh cool so my she's now
my stepdaughter but I'm gonna adopt her
and she'll be my doctor how old was she
when you met uh your fiance a year and a
half she was a year and a half she was a
year and a half old and she's three now
wow also in her eyes your dad I'm daddy
she calls me Daddy yeah oh and uh yeah
so it's you know it's uh I have 22 17
and three
wow that's amazing you were married
before then I was yeah I was married for
25 years
um I have a 22 year old son who's at USC
studying art amazing got a semester left
there and then my daughter will be a
high school senior she's 17. wow she
lives with her mom and then you were
with over 20 married 25 years yeah you
know her and I were together for ten
were no longer wow right right you still
have a relationship with her okay uh no
I mean we're still working on it it's
okay it's ups and downs right right I I
we're like
and there's just not a lot of
communication outside of okay Logistics
and things and I you know well it just
it just like everything just giving it
time yeah yeah yeah he's really worried
that he will never fall in love again
and I think that he's wrong like I think
it can happen at any time yeah I feel
like I'm not did you feel that or no
like what after your marriage you think
you will be able to find somebody or uh
I mean it would vary you know like there
are there were definitely times where I
was like yeah you know I could I could
live alone you know yeah I could I
and I'm not necessarily built for it
because I do a lot better when there's
other people around just in terms of
getting stuff done because when I'm on
my own I can do nothing yeah yeah yeah
for a long time I mean like I've been so
we live together in this house yeah and
she walked upstairs today and there's
like a smell it's just I cannot believe
the state that this house is in I when I
left it was speaking well my mom still
comes to clean yeah what
my mom misses baseball collar yeah he
calls my mom oh I travel it smells like
[__] but you only call her when he's
bringing a date home ah what and that's
what she doesn't like he's like he calls
me last minute and I know it's because
he's you know you either bringing a girl
or whatever oh you're the only one
but the house is just in a like
disrepair yeah I mean everything I don't
know who's chewing the walls I ate
cereal out of a cat Bowl
clean the other Bowl I couldn't do it
but your walls are chewed in who's
chewing the walls we don't I chew walls
the dogs are with me no no wouldn't be
the walls are true what the corner of
like the molding there's like just it's
just a little mold that's the dates
clawing to get out
they're crawling along baseboards
better down here it seems to rise
look they're sure there's a lock on the
door but they wanted it in there it's
for their protection
um so I was so
about a year ago I was offered this
thing that you did
and I came close to doing it oh right
right so I came close to doing it but
I'm like I don't know it seems weird I
don't know what it is and it just it
turned out I said no this is the one
they shot in Australia yeah it was the
Marshal yeah yeah so